un jour avec les indépendantistes
réunionnais le week-end dernier le lplp
l'organisation populaire pour l'ibère
nout péi organisées dans les hauts de
saint leu
les assises de la décolonisation la
création à d'un état réunionnais a été
décrété un chef de gouvernement à
bernard grondin a même été désigné jean
marc collienne et thomas le moullec
l'ont suivi pendant cette journée
considérée comme historique par les
indépendantistes réunionnais même s'il
était seulement quelques dizaines à y
assister
le drapeau indépendantiste clottes
aujourd'hui sur les oat salut nous
sommes auplata tan rouge c'est ici que
le lplp l'organisation pour libérer nos
deux pays a décidé d'organiser son
assemblée anticoloniale ça débute dans
un instant enfin ça devrait débuter car
pour le moment il n'y a pas grand monde
sous le chapiteau installé dans cette
prairie du quartier tan rouge
mais bernard grondin reste optimiste
qu'on fait des endroits comme ça sur le
mont de marsan en retard le chemin de
mon nid viennent dans normale en a plein
de talent en train d'arriver
tee shirt noir talkie walkie le service
d'ordre du parti indépendantiste
accueilli les militants qui continuent à
arriver au compte gouttes
hall a choisi cet ordre de m parce que
cette année nous fait l'écho mais plutôt
les 206 ans la révolte calcin le et les
camps des principaux camps de marrons
était valable
le plaza chaloupe donc en rouge entend
tout ça tout ça c'était une zone de
combat on met l endroit le plus de tout
ça décoiffe comédie un meilleur endroit
pour faire un grand l'assemblée contre
l'oniam l'on comprenne mon body blanc à
la paix la zone garros 01 40 voix mais
il arrive donc on attend donc un petit
peu et quand maximum va arriver à ce
moment là ben va commencer et non un
trou d'un petit instant finalement la
séance démarre avec plus d'une heure de
retard
il y à ce moment là une trentaine de
personnes dans la salle
d'autres arriveront plus tard mais ils
ne seront jamais plus de 50 sous le
chapiteau mystères aujourd'hui que nous
voulons mettre en place car les
responsables du fplp ont bien
l'intention de jeter aujourd'hui les
bases du futur état réunionnais une
première étape mettre en place le grand
conseil neuf candidats se sont déclarés
ils seront chargés de rédiger la
constitution du futur état
pendant ces messieurs félix pour élire
leur président les membres du conseil
sont certes en pleine assemblée mais
saclay important il faut que tout le
monde y va ça nous fait non considéré à
l'unanimité
élu président félix klein est élu
président du grand conseil
mais les militants indépendantistes ne
veulent pas en rester là ils ont décidé
de désigner aujourd'hui un chef de
gouvernement qui ça s'est pas entendus a
fait un bond ces responsabilités là ça
fait bernard
bien que benno finalement un autre
candidat se manifeste qui ça et bottes
pour bernard godard en tant que chef du
gouvernement
là c'est tout à l'issue du vote le porte
parole du lp lp est élue à une large
majorité
mais là je me souviens 6 donc c'est le
chef élu chef de gouvernement même si
c'est seulement par quelques dizaines de
militants bernard grondin prend alors la
parole et propose d'emblée de voter une
première loi
le chef du gouvernement contre coloniale
il proposa un loi imaginé inde à fin
août fête nationale réunionnais la 206
en bons instincts saint leu la levée
pour la liberté nous dessine même le 5
novembre comme le jour le plus important
au notre pays
5 novembre fête nationale réunionnais
notre 5 novembre le fait de considérer
la 2d
[Applaudissements]
et le principal c'est que nous les
arrivées et que nous ils arrivent à
mettre en place les premiers outils ta
réunionnais ne programme pas
l'indépendance
donc pour balla ne programme pas
l'indépendance mais ça ne l'a fait
aujourd'hui c'est la programmation mais
à réunionnais n république libre un avis
public lit indépendant au service des
réunionnais merci à vous monsieur
premier ministre maintenant le premier
ministre libre au gouvernement les
ministres doivent avoir
nous avons fait en général et les
mystères comme mon français estime me
sers régalien et dans les prochains
jours le gouvernement sera mis en place
et pourra travailler la dépendance c'est
pas maintenant et corse alors là c'est
le peuple qui dure c'est pas bien bon
teint qui moi me imagine me marier mais
j'imagine
j aimerais tu sois le plus tôt possible
mais c'est le peuple qui décidera
c'est le grand l'assemblée à un moment
donné décidera aujourd'hui nous mais que
les outils en place
fini les discours ont valu maintenant
discuter un peu avec bernard grondin
autour d'un carry
d'abord bernard grondin va devoir
s'expliquer sur ses déclarations à
propos des oreilles je suis anti
oreilles at il déclaré un jour mais pas
raciste
obama dit comme ça me disais que quand
vous nous fait nous dénonce ne dénonce
pas et moon the rain ou cette posture
c'est le français quand ils sont en
france avant d'y arriver si il devient
oreilles par kilomètre du match il
l'habille coloniale plus il annula
codienne conseil faut faire il ya là
pour prendre place via ni la mondiale
lui connaît mais nous ne connais pas je
la montre lui de l'amour de nouveaux
élus respectent pas nos la pâte ils
respectent pas nos goûts veut nous nous
respectons mais la pause racisme et tout
l'état le créole sera la langue
officielle
nous on va proposer c'est que le creux
de la langue nationale n'ont par
définition la langue la langue
officielle ou connaît l'argument de ceux
qui vous seront présents ils disent
toujours si nous il est dépendant aux
genoux sera misère ne sera mise m sera
madagascar nous mangera genou premier
jeu du goût de l'état réunionnais nous
mangeons saucisses aux grossistes /
games un peu de riz est toujours la main
c'est à nous réunionnais et aux
différentes de différents institutions
que nous la mettre en place donne à nous
les moyens pour que notre pape y vivent
et qui vivent bien le push faudra le de
retrousse ses manches et du travail le
maintien au travail avec fierté pour son
pays que nous mettons au service de son
pays et que nous compterons sa fierté et
de tout ensemble c'est pas la terre qui
manque ici et ici
la réunion tout à fait y pousse à nous
battre les moyens pour faire en sorte
que la réunion devient autosuffisant
déjà alimentaire au niveau alimentaire
et dans les autres domaines
flora nous à nouveau avancer ça va être
à nous de définir ensemble toutes
ensemble définir tout ça une fois
d'armes ou fait pour que notre pays des
viable de la matin économiquement et
pour les indépendantistes réunionnais la
journée va se terminer en musique avec
ce qui pourrait devenir
le national réunionnais n 7 c'est marc
amoudry n'ont pour le moment il s'agit
seulement d'un fonker des paroles qui
seront bientôt mises en musique une
nation réunionnaise ce dimanche là ils
n'étaient que quelques-uns à la
proclamer mai
tu